hi I'm John Woodard with Wolf on
blockchain labs we're a new subsidiary
of Wolfram research we work on a lot of
the blockchain related items and at WTC
and 2019 I'm talking about our education
and research initiatives mainly that's
about an introductory blockchain MOOC
that talks about what the economic
issues issues around society and issues
around the technology of blockade and
accompanying technologies in addition we
have another project role the blockchain
so it's dealing with collecting
different attributes on blockades around
the now like hundreds of black chains
that are out there to prove useful for
people to search through and look and
kind of discover the ones that are most
useful for their projects
I'm John Woodard and I'm going to be
covering research and education
initiatives in I think it was blockchain
in there but I just kind of changed that
a little bit to decentralize
technologies so first I really wanted to
give an outline of why it might be
interesting to learn about blockchain
and decentralized technologies we have a
couple of things that we're working on
an introductory course along with
collecting all the various deities that
are out there along with their
attributes and so that's that
decentralized project data then I'll
talk a little bit about kind of the
future and what distributed ledger
technologies might enable in terms of
autonomous sort of projects so a little
bit about Wolfram blockchain labs we
started as far as I think collecting and
using blockchain related stuff with
Wolfram Alpha and like maybe 2014 in
terms of adding prices that's also
available in currency convert as a
Wolfram language function later on we we
added an instance of multi-chain which
is a permissions ledger which is also
accessible via Wolfram language and then
we started adding additional public
block chains Bitcoin aetherium arc and
we're working on others there we also
since I think around 2014 have been used
with lots of decentralized services as
actually in Oracle where people use data
from Wolfram Alpha to enable operational
clauses in smart contracts so that's how
folks have been using this now and with
Wolfram blockchain labs who kind of
collected all those projects around the
Wolfram research into one entity I
thought it mentioned a little bit about
the Wolfram Bakhtin labs team we have a
number of engineers we also have
cryptographer and an economist so and
then myself is sort of a business person
so we have a real intimate
interdisciplinary team which is really
helpful for blockchain because there's
so many different topics that come up in
terms of using it in fact I think
Christian Pascal who's on here kind of
characterized blockchains is kind of new
economic societies and that's something
really interesting and useful to think
about because they're trying to organize
economic activity and that sort of both
the sort of the currency aspect along
with the public blockchains to record
that that activity so I wanted to go to
into a bit of history you'll notice this
talk is far more about research and
collecting so we understand what
technologies are out there and are
important then the actual technology
itself
I think Akira and Pierrot are giving a
talk right after launch that it will go
more into our initiatives actually
integrating technology into Wolfram
language so this is kind of like an
informal web area arizim in a way the
zero sort of era is like research and
the non-commercial web with ARPANET sort
of starting then getting the go-ahead
and around maybe 95 to commercialise and
having that first burst of commercial
services some of those still exist
Amazon eBay others then web to kind of
the participate but participatory web a
lot around social so I think a lot of
people characterize Flickr and that has
a service it was a photo service where
people could upload their own own photos
they could do comments we kind of had
blogs and other stuff in this area so it
was really kind of this democratization
of the web in many ways there's also
this sort of growth of semantic and
machine readable data some folks kind of
call that maybe web 3 I like to call it
web 2 because a lot of people in this
decentralized era characterize that as
web 3 so that's this era where Bitcoin
kind of kicks off kicks it off but in
many ways Bitcoin and what
so Satoshi Nakamoto was able to do
actually was a long progression of
people kind of
waise turned off by I guess the
commercialization of the web
there was this whoa
there was this cypherpunk mailing list
which was this combination of cypher and
punk to come up with the cyberpunk idea
and really I would say like the core
idea behind that was taking cryptography
to provide secrecy and privacy for users
to really kind of try to make this
promise a lot of people thought of with
web sort of zero possible for average
people that they would be able to have
secure communications without kind of
the prying eyes in a way looking at
their communications and so Nakamoto in
many ways took this idea with Bitcoin as
a peer-to-peer electronic cash system
and took all of these ideas into a new
system and that goes back to talking
about this is kind of this new society
in a way so one of the kind of
interesting concepts in looking again at
those eras of web growth is an idea of
an economist Joseph Schumpeter talking
about creative discreate of destruction
and that's kind of that in capitalism
you have old ideas old products that
will be kind of destroyed by upcoming
new technologies and new ideas Clayton
Christensen actually has another sort of
slight version of that that you hear a
lot about and that's disruption Clayton
Christensen's idea is that it's kind of
you have existing services that add
features and they're kind of disrupted
by newer cheaper services and often that
happens with changes in technology that
incumbents aren't able to really deal
with when it comes to sort of
decentralized technologies and this is
why I kind of included that in the title
rather than blockchain distributed level
ledger technologies or blockchains
basically
grass and other sort of things there's
no clear sort of definition some people
want certain attributes to always be
included other people don't and then
there are decentralized services or
layer to services like identity services
file services I think last night Stephan
talked about our connection to ipfs or
interplanetary file system which is a
decentralized file storage system so
this is just this idea huge change that
maybe this 10% GDP will happen I don't
know if that's really accurate by world
economic forum but it does have the
ability to affect a lot of different
services that are out there I think in
particular because it's this newer
technology that developing countries may
reimagine and build services solely
using more distributed project projects
like we kind of see with going from
[Music]
telephone services and not being able to
lay copper wire actually because of
corruption and people just stealing the
wire to being able to have mobile
services and really getting the leap
ahead of existing technologies it could
be the same case when it comes to
consumer services government services
and even as money in particular when it
comes to developing economies and so
that might allow them to be more
efficient and kind of actually leapfrog
ahead when it comes to wolfram
blockchain labs in our approach to these
technologies you'll you'll hear from
akhirin bureau after lunch as far as the
integrations that we've done that's like
with Bitcoin aetherium arc and others
and computational facts I think Steven
talked a little bit about that last
night
now for the really this topic is more
about this education and research one
we're creating this introductory
blockchain course which I think a lot of
people have questions about
whether the technology will be
interesting and useful in other ways
beyond this idea of Bitcoin and digital
currency so it's really talking about
that and then also this world of
blockchains which is trying to collect
all these different projects that are
out there and then collect attributes on
their block chains both in terms of the
technology and the protocols that
they've created but then also in terms
of the activity on the block chains
themselves again going back to the fact
that they're kind of creating these
communities the course really focuses on
actually history of money shouldn't be
like like all these things are under it
but understanding modern money and the
changes and kind of money as a
technology that it's changed broadly
over time also the governance of public
networks that are out there like Bitcoin
like aetherium you have people who are
making changes based on votes and things
that they've kind of kind of created so
it has to do not only with the Kahn
technology but it's also behavioral
economics politics and social structure
again because they're behavioral aspects
of this and that people are kind of
creating these communities
so this is a reimagining of Paul Behrens
illustration of nodes and using it for
communication networks it's done
actually in Wolfram language and he had
this idea I think during the Cold War
we're trying to figure out okay well
what kind of communication system would
actually survive like a nuclear event
and the idea was this distributed
network would do just that
with equal nodes and nodes that we're
capable of communicating with each other
and this is something that a lot of
decentralized projects have taken to
note that's why we kind of included here
is that this is kind of the system that
they're trying to design so
one of the interesting system one of the
interesting things with all of these
different systems and how people have
built kind of distributed networks over
time is that there's different ways of
kind of characterizing what kind of a
blockchain is and what a community
around the blockchain might be Napster
is kind of an early thing where
centralized and then you had things like
because Napster was centralized as a
somewhat distributed network it did have
centralized servers people were able to
attack it so you had Kazak come with
that was more decentralized where there
were peer-to-peer systems and that made
it harder to actually take down ghazan
became this huge file sharing system so
you kind of see the same with how people
are developing and designing blockchain
public networks we have ripple kind of
there as an example again like it's kind
of a centralized blockchain and there
are also other ways to think about block
chains in terms of like how they'll
support copyright how they'll think
about actual law and jurisdiction and
other stuff so it's kind of trying to
rank rank those so anytime you talk
about distributed Ledger's or block
chains it's kind of may be useful to
think of a basic kind of example of this
kind of progression and we do that of
course in the MOOC kind of multiple
times we build it up from kind of a very
basic explanation to kind of a toy
example that's actually using Wolfram
language that isn't as sophisticated
naturally as like Bitcoin or aetherium
but kind of gives people the flavor of
the cryptography that that's used and
then go to a full examination of
nakamoto's paper but not really in in in
super detail at a high at a high enough
level that people can get a lot out of
it without kind of going into code so
one of the things that I think about and
the reason why I usually like to talk
about
blockchains as being distributed
Ledger's is that it really comes from
this idea of a ledger and kind of in in
this case it's this old accounting
ledger where you can enter in
transactions and you have like one
canonical ledger and you can kind of see
how that might be difficult and
problematic if someone we're going to
say cheat this ledger they might have
one public facing book where they're
entering in transactions and then have
another book kind of under the table
that they're manipulating their
transactions with and if you only have
access to the public facing book you'd
be in trouble you can also think about
that as well that you know the person
who really controls the ledger kind of
controls everything in a way and the
idea like and people went from this
paper ledger of course to digital
centralized Ledger's and the idea with
well the way I think about Nakamoto and
really kind of the brilliance behind
taking all of these services and ideas
from the cypherpunk mailing list and
building it into Bitcoin as a
peer-to-peer electronic cash is that
it's the idea of liberating people from
this centralized system so rather than
you know a central banker having this
ledger where they are printing money you
have a community where anyone who wants
to and has the capability could run a
node and with those nodes these
transactions where you know one person
would be entering them in on this ledger
you can give your transaction to a node
the node can give it to the min pool
when someone solves a cryptographic
problem and has the right to add a new
block they'll collect those transactions
and add them to the blockade so it's
kind of in a way trying to take power
from the centralized ledger folks
whatever that centralized organization
might be and kind of distribute that in
a community where everyone could run it
up so that's kind of a brief talk about
the technology kind of aspect one of the
things that we found and really like as
a theme in the course is actually money
as technology as well so early you know
people starting with tokens and kind of
the high priest kind of having control
of these tokens and control of defining
what money is and being able to have
control over contracts as well and how
those contracts would be executed to now
maybe some of those powers interested in
the government and central bank's having
control again of the money supply and
how laws will be interpreted and
executed
- maybe this which is the Facebook Libre
logo which if you've seen any of the
things recently they're getting a lot of
heat over trying to kind of take this
control of what money is and in issuing
money from central bankers which has
made them very very nervous because it
basically be taken away monetary policy
or tools in monetary policy
so this is an interesting Venn diagram
of this money flower by Becca and rot
and it's kind of this idea of trying to
look at these different currencies that
folks are using and and are being issued
it's kind of a tautology of money and
we're trying to explore and sort of
categorize the things that exist that
are out there so that's kind of where
this blockchain MOOC kind of ends where
again we're trying to explore both the
technology and we're using Wolfram
language a lot for that along with the
great tools from Wolfram you folks that
aspect along with the economics and
social aspects to really give people a
lot of insight into how these things are
going to be used and how they influence
things beyond just Bitcoin because I
think a lot of central bankers at first
were sort of contemptuous of Bitcoin and
you know thought about it as being a
joke but if you look at Bitcoin kind of
influencing other digital currencies
namely like telegram which has something
that's out there that's his conning gun
under the radar to Facebook's Libre
which people certainly take very
seriously
and China in terms of coming out with a
digital rim be soon like this has had an
awful lot of influence so the
technologies themselves are also having
a lot of influence so the other sort of
project again is like collecting these
DLTS trying to get an idea of how many
are out there I haven't really played
this interactive but does anyone have a
guess about how many DL T's there might
be out there
public D LTS 5,000 nope way too high
well maybe I don't know but what we've
been able to find is about 400 and I
should have actually included permission
ones as well although there's very small
number just some examples there's like
multi-chain that we use
our public ones that we have integrated
Bitcoin aetherium arc vertical kind of
applications I would say like coins ones
that are like specific to things like
games and then agreements which are like
smart contracts and other stuff so the
thing here is that I actually overheard
a conversation earlier was like oh you
know Bitcoin can only support like maybe
seven transactions that's not useful
enough yeah yes that's true with Bitcoin
there are other sort of block chains
that are public networks that are out
there that claim to support more
transactions of course it doesn't really
matter if you don't have the
transactions where people are using it
but the goal of this project is to
really not only collect the DL T's that
are out there but collect attributes
about them both the static attributes
actually think I have another slide here
what's the static things like the
consensus methods that they use their
first sort of block or Genesis block
it's really tells you when they
initiated as a public network the
founders and then computable things you
know what we love at Wolfram the average
transactions that they have in a block
who cares if you have if you can support
ten thousand and you only have to in in
a block and then things like the average
transfer amounts to kind of see again
the economic activity that's taking
place oh and let me say a little bit
about proof of work and proof of stake
proof of work is what Bitcoin uses as a
consensus method so it's just
computational power one of the things
that's interesting there is that I think
for Bitcoin as a public blockchain it
takes about the power resources of a
think like Denmark which is kind of
daunting because you would see if like
if this scales an order of magnitude
like that's a lot of resources going to
essentially nothing proof of stake is
another sort of way where people either
do it on the basis of how how much of
the token you actually hold and they do
like a lottery the more you hold the
greater probability that you'll get the
right to determine the next block
so lastly I wanted to talk a little bit
about the Economist feature because this
to me is like the most interesting part
and it has more to do that with the
technology then the kind of the crypto
currency and crypto currency kind of
bubble around you know Bitcoin being
worth whatever it's more than
technologies themselves so I got this
from the folks at McKinsey but I like it
because you know we could have all of
these things out here that behave in
this kind of autonomous or
semi-autonomous fashion whether it's the
the cars people are on phones doing
contracts Internet of Things kind of
communicating and really thinking about
like smart contracts and computational
contracts all of these things need sort
of data which we absolutely have it at
Wolfram along with computational
contracts that we're kind of developing
because in this world we could imagine
where cars are kind of autonomous and
maybe you're in the situation where you
need to go somewhere really fast and now
cars are way safer so you can pay people
to pass them on the interstate well all
of those things are going to be
contracts you're going to need to be
have them behave in an autonomous
fashion you're not going to want to you
know click pay pay pay pay to pass
people so I think that kind of gives an
idea of how these technologies might be
used in the future for the good of
humanity in many ways beyond just this
idea of whether these currencies will
kind of have staying power which you
know I'm not really so sure about so
that's that's the end any questions